you're now live chair
right everybody um i'd like to welcome
you all to this virtual meeting
um on the fourth of uh february it's
this special meeting it wasn't a
scheduled one
i'll just go through some basic rules
for this meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones
except mine um please leave all
microphones muted
unless you're asked to speak by me
residents who want to exercise this
right of taking part in the
meeting have been asked to register in
advance
and also have the option of sending the
statement to us
which will be read out by an officer or
they've been sent a link to temporarily
join the meeting to speak in person
we've got what we did have we did have
seven registered to speak today
we're down to one now um
to indicate to me that you'd like to
speak and i think
they're committing all this by now you
or a second emotion
please press a symbol raising your hand
uh in the participants menu on your
screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they're pressed
and i will deal with them in that order
and giving the appropriate officer or
counsellor
the opportunity to answer in between
where necessary
and i'll also return to the counsellor
to check that they're happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with the democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube
channel i ask all
of you to be patient during this meeting
and to understand that processes
and advice may take a little longer than
usual
and we do we don't have any technical
hitches
i'll now ask sandra to
introduce or ask each committee member
to introduce themselves
and then the officers present as well
thanks sandra thank you chair
councillor belton yeah good morning i'm
richard bout and i represent heartland
ward
pence lebron i'm councillor margaret
brown i represent great torrington
councillor christie good morning my name
is peter christie i represent biddeford
north
councillor craigie good morning
i'm ruth craigie i represent biddeford
east and i apologize if i keep sneezing
and blowing my nose
i seem to have a bit of a cold at the
moment
councillor leather yeah good morning
everybody councillor chris leather and
i represent northern ward
councillor lock good morning i'll get up
the rosary lock and i represent the
world of two rivers and three moors
councillor mcgoff
not present that's what i thought thank
you tom
councillor watson yeah pete watson broad
eth
and councillor wiseman hello i'm
councillor richard wiseman i represent
the shebian langtry ward
thank you chad thank you sandra could
the officers present please introduce
themselves
starting with sean harrington please uh
good morning members good morning
members of public my name is sean
harrington and i'm the planning manager
at our district council
good morning members members of public
my name's damian hunter and i'm the
legal services manager for today's
district council
good morning members good morning
members of the general public my name is
tracy blackmore i'm a principal planner
here at torres district council
good morning uh members and members of
the public i'm chrissy glee playing
officer toyota council
ash everybody i think in that yeah okay
thank you uh right item one on the on
the agenda is apologies for absence
have we had any apologies sandra no
chair no apologies
okay thank you item two is declarations
of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately and the expressed views of
that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
item three on the agenda is to agree
the agendas between parts one and two
well there isn't any part two
item four is urgent matters uh
the only information i've got is that
our first uh sorry
one of our applications has been
withdrawn which is a coaching horse's
application at buckland brewer
which is one oblique zero six
three six oblique 2020 the full
application
and also the listed building one for the
coaching horses
one oblate0637
2020 uh a listed building
they've been withdrawn so they won't be
before us this morning sean you've got
your hand up yep
uh thank you chair just one further mata
following
withdrawn applications at the last
meeting councilman mcguff
asked for a statement from devon county
council's education authority
in relation to the section 106
contributions i have now received that
statement so if the chair is happy i can
read that statement out now to committee
yeah thanks sean uh so the statement
from devon county council reads
devon county council is bound by the
legal obligations defined in a related
section 106 agreement as to how and
where the education contributions can be
spent
where we are able to secure
contributions for a specific school
the school will be named in the section
106 agreement
where the contributions are secured for
wider area strategy
e.g for a new primary school in a town a
specific school
may not be named within the agreement
however the legal agreement will
differentiate whether the contributions
are for primary
secondary early years special education
or school transport provision
as such money secured for primary can
only be used for primary expansion
secondary contributions can only be used
to enhance secondary provision etc
in addition education contributions
secured for a geographical area
cannot be diverted elsewhere eg funding
secured for bidiford cannot be used in
great torrington
and i hope that gives members some some
comfort in relation to the education of
variety
we've also had an offer that a member of
the education of rt can come to
committee in the future uh to discuss
this further if members will find that
useful
thank you chair well lovely thanks sean
uh councillor watson and then council a
lot got your hands up yeah
can we can we have a reason why why
these two have been withdrawn while
we're online
or is it private
shall i answer yes thank you sean yeah
so both applications were drawn
yesterday as
the the applicant didn't want them to be
decided or
be determined by the local planning
authority and
didn't wish them to go to this committee
they may be resubmitted in due course
but if they are they'll be subject to
the normal process of playing
application with a different reference
number and consultation etc
all right thanks joe yeah well
that's the prerogative of the applicant
yeah
no i know officers have done a lot of
work on those two applications but
they have been withdrawn and that's it
council lock yeah can i just come back
on that statement that sean's just read
about unless a school is particularly
named into section 106
is that something then that the plans
committee could do in their
um if they approve something could they
condition that
a particular school is named in the
condition
so it is in the 106. uh it would be in
the gift of the
members to do that what i would say is
there could be some consequences about
that for example if a school wasn't to
come forward
and that education contribution could be
used elsewhere in the same area
so we'd probably want to discuss that
with the education authority and
if that was the case we may wish to
defer the application for further
discussions
thank you councillor christie yes can i
just come back on the coaching horses
one
um this has happened before where
applicants have withdrawn
an application at the last moment and
it's then resubmitted later but do the
objections that have been put in
do they carry over or do you have to
write back in because on previous
occasions
uh objections to the first application
seem to have disappeared or at least not
taken into account
can they be carried over uh
yes if i can answer that one again chair
yeah
um no they won't be carried over because
they have to be considered within the
round of that actual application
uh what we do as a local authority is we
do contact anybody who objected the
first time around
so even if they aren't in etc we will
write to them and let them know that a
new application has been submitted
but we will require a fresh um letter of
representation within the application
thank you uh councillor pennington who
wants to speak
on the buckland brewer one not a member
of this committee but
i shall let councillor pennington speak
thank you chair i did submit a request
to speak when that came up this morning
um
two questions both on what you've
discussed this morning um
winkley on the winty side some children
go to
north devon schools in germany etcetera
and on the heartland side go the blue
haven
during debuted is it possible for
cornwall county council or
north devon district council areas to
make requests of torres district council
planning monies
um and uh watch that one fresh if you
can i'll come back on the second one
then in a minute
come on yeah thank you councillor
pennington um
we would only be looking at requests
within this area in our district
i think technically that question will
probably be better answered by the
education authority
um as opposed to myself so it may be
that we wish for
a member of education party to come to a
future committee to discuss these
matters
yeah okay i know it's public i know but
i'm just going to ask about
the viabilities of clubs in general um i
think if you look at the minutes
of the presentation that was going to go
today i think one of the grounds for
refusing was on the grounds of viability
how were the covered situation affect um
other pubs coming through in the area
put in an application because viability
um will be a lot stronger argument for
them
to change abuse now given the culvert
situation and how will your
planners view those arguments not
specifically the coaching horses
but other hospitality um situations who
are a business you know may come back in
and ask for residential to come into
place can i ask how that would affect
your review
on the viability argument
uh yes council pennington um it's a
difficult question to answer as we
assess each application on its own
merits
um so we'd have to look at the
applications as they came in and the
information provided
you're quite correct there will be an
impact um from covid which we'd have to
take into account
um as everybody's aware in this pandemic
world that we're living in at the moment
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future
so we will consider that but there are
other matters as well as our abilities
that we look at
in relation to these changes of use of
public houses
and we'd have to assess each one on its
merits when that viability information
came in
thank you very much chair thank you very
much sean for your responses
thank you i will just mention that on
the
contributions the education
contributions
uh mindful of the one at um down bayview
road in northern
there's no name for a school there yet
there is a site in that
application for a school but there's no
name for the school yet
but that contribution is can only be
spent in northern on a new primary
school
so it should hopefully be on that site
behind bayview road on dagon hill farm
but there's no name yet for the school
but the money the site is there
so uh yeah but i think sean it would be
a good idea
to have somebody from the education
authority come along to speak to us
i mean it may be that they when we've
got one of these
applications coming up again well most
of them have for education contribution
they could join that meeting then
i'll leave it yesterday i'll invite
somebody um
one of the next committees nippon all
right thanks sean
okay we move on then um public
participation
uh this is where i advise the committee
of
prior requests to speak by members of
the public well there were as i said six
speakers listed for the coaching horses
one
they've that's all gone now so we've
only won and that's
for the merryfield farm one at bridge
rule application
kenji who's the applicant wants to speak
to that
so that's public participant this
morning
um
right we move on item six is planning
applications the the information
uh recommendations and advice contained
in the reports
are correct at the date of preparation
which is more than ten days in advance
of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing
or orally at the committee meeting
now we move on to applications the first
one is
is 6a application which is
doug juggies field shebia
and that's on pages 5 to 15.
could you just note that councilman
mcguffin
all right thank you we've got a full
house now then
okay thank you um and tracy tracy
blackwater playing officer
will give us this presentation over to
you tracy
thank you chair so this is a reserve
matters application for seven dwellings
considering
access appearance landscaping layout and
scale
this was following the granting of
outline planning commission for up to
eight dwellings of all matters reserved
to grant
on the 16th of august 2018.
so the application is before members due
to the applicant being a member of staff
at torridge district council
there are no updates for members to
consider from the writing of the report
so the application site is for proposed
seven dwellings and as you can see
that's outlined in red
the allowance out land outlined in blue
to the south is also with the
applicant's ownership
so this is an aerial photo of the site
site has been identified with a red
arrow as members can see the application
site is located approximately one
kilometer to the east of the village of
shebia
and the application site is currently in
open field and measures approximately
0.3 hectares in size
so just having a look at a couple of
photos of the site so this is a view of
the existing field access
located to the northern boundary of the
site which currently provides the access
onto the adjacent highway this is a view
looking into the site from the field
access
this is a view from the site as members
can see the site is well
screened with mature hedgerows and trees
to the boundary of the site
[Applause]
this is another view this is so from
again within the site this is a view
looking east and showing the eastern
hedgerow boundary
and then this is looking west and
showing that western mature hedgerow
boundary this is just a google street
view just to get
members of context it shows the adjacent
highway which really does lead on to the
village of shebia
so moving on to the proposal uh the
prophet this is the proposed site plan
demonstrating the proposed sighting of
the seven dwellings around a central
spine road
that utilizes the existing vehicle
access to the north of the site
the spine road is approximately 65
metres in length and as members can see
there's a turning head indicated at the
southern end
so this is the site slightly zoomed in
just to guide members there are four
dwellings located to the west and three
dwellings to the east of the spine road
so the scheme provides for free free bed
dwellings and four
four bed dwellings plots six and seven
which
members will be able to see to the
bottom right
i'll just zoom in for you provides for
two affordable units being three bedroom
units
and the tenure being one for social rent
and one for intermediate provision
so just moving on to the house types of
the scheme
so the proposal includes four four bed
detached open market dwellings the
dwellings are to be finished with a
combination of render
weatherproof cladding natural stone
under a slate roof
the proposed floor plans indicate an
open planned kitchen
separate and dining rooms separate
utility
living room and study to the ground
floor
and the first floor has four bedrooms
two of ensuites and a bathroom
and there is an attached garage facility
for these dwellings
so there is to be one free bed detached
open market dwellings
swelling again the dwelling is to finish
with a combination of render
weatherproof cladding natural stone
under a slate roof
the proposed floor plans for this
dwelling again
show a living room dining kitchen room
separate utility area three bedrooms and
a bath from upstairs
so the next slide shows the two times
three beds semi-detached dwellings which
as
i said members will be affordable
dwellings um
they are have two off-road car parking
spaces to serve the dwellings
so the next slide demonstrates a
cross-section drawing of the site
looking to the east
so from the left of the plan members can
see the two semi-detached dwellings
which they will be the affordable units
in the middle
is the four bed open market unit and to
the right
is the free bed open market dwelling
and then another cross-section drawing
looking to the east of the site now
which demonstrates three of the four bed
uh
open market dwellings of the ski
so moving on to the planning
considerations so the principle of
development
it is noted that the site is outside of
the development boundary for shebia
notwithstanding the current
current position for the council are
able to provide a five-year housing land
supply
in this instance the application site
has the benefit of outline planning
permission remains extant with the
current application
providing the reserve matters therefore
on this basis the principle of this
development
site has previously been established and
accepted
scale appearance layouts landscaping and
impact on the character and
appearance of the area the site layout
consists of a traditional street with
properties facing the road
the scale of the development would
appear as two-story dwellings
it is accepted that the site will change
the character of the site from a green
field to residential development
however the retention of the existing
mature hedge banks and the provision of
additional soft planting
will insist assimilating the development
into that surrounding rural landscape
statement uh the submitted plans
proposed seven dwellings which are
traditional
design with pitch roofs and gable
features
and as i said the application proposes a
comprehensive landscaping scheme to
include a new species
native species hedgerow to the front and
southern boundary
so moving on residential immunity there
is adequate separation distance from
third party properties to ensure the
immunities of existing properties
uh residential properties would not be
harmed the highway authority have
assessed the proposal and have no
objections to the overall layout and
parking proposed
and ecology an updated statement has
been submitted by the agent to confirm
there is no significant change to the
site respect to ecology and protected
species from the granting of the
outlying planning commission
um and just to sort of mention to
members the agent has confirmed that
a deed of variation for the section 106
agreement
which was submitted in conjunction with
the outline
there will be a deed of variation
submitted this is set out in members
report
this will include amendments to the size
of affordable housing to reflect the
current need now required
public open spaces to provide an
off-site commute to some rather than the
on-site which was originally
uh written into the section 106. this is
due to the constrained nature of the
site just not being able to fit
that open market and that open space
onto the site
and the traffic scheme there is some
clarification with devon county council
highway officers and the applicant
of uh how that traffic scheme is going
to work
so overall the overall recommendation
for
our members is for the approval of the
reserve matters application
thank you chair thank you jason thanks
for that presentation
you would like to start the discussion
on this
well i uh counselor lock
yeah just cover the points um as we've
just seen the scheme has been reduced to
seven units from the original eight
but i'm still i'm pleased to see that um
the applicant is still providing two
affordable units
and that the time has been agreed with
um rachel
one of the comments that the parish
council made because they would have
liked to see the affordable
units have carriages but i mean rachel
has replied that
she has never known affordable units be
supplied with garages so i think that
gets over the concerns of the parish
council for that one
yeah um
but with regard to the size of the
houses on page 10
um the local estate agents say that
there are sufficient numbers of small
houses in sheffield
and i do know cheviot quite well and i
do agree with that
and i think really people are now
looking to buy three and four bedroom
units
because the way we work um several more
people will be working from home i think
after the pandemic
and look into for more bedrooms to
change one into an office so i've got no
problem with the size of the houses
um tracy touch on the
106. so at this stage we don't
know which public open space will
benefit from any 106 monies
or how much that would be that's early
days yet tracy is that
yeah if yes that's right chair so i have
um been in contact with shelby a
um parish clerk um and they have um
outlined a number of schemes that i
think that that money could go towards
um in sort of liaison with our staff
adrian avery
i think there are a number of projects
that um will benefit from the off-site
open space and as i said
hopefully that would be more of a sort
of general public benefit to shelby's
wider community
um rather than on site space which
obviously probably would be more enjoyed
by the occupiers as opposed to that
wider community
yeah thank you for that so i mean i will
listen to what other chaos have got to
say but the paris council
highways have got no objection the
environmental protection have got no
objection so i would recommend that the
application is approved
thank you council lot councillor watson
oh yeah thanks sir
yeah here again rose as
took away a lot of my thunder she's
she's she's asked all the questions
um and i too i i totally agree with what
she said
uh and also it does comply with st04
dmo4 and dmo8
no 5-year land supply housing mix to me
is very good
we've already got the principle of
development um
so yeah if rose is going to
propose it i'll second it thanks
councillor watson
anybody else like to make comment on the
application
yes yes please chair i can't raise a
yellow hand
councilman yes thank you um
with regard to the two affordable houses
i knew that they're together and no
garages and we can see the explanation
for that
but they are easily identified as
affordable houses with no garages
and that is again the poor relation it's
not getting what
might be needed um so i think that is
regrettable they should be separated and
not easily identified
thank you chair thanks council brown
that that occurred to me we've always
said that
any affordable um offers
shouldn't be should be indistinguishable
from the rest of the development
but for the very reason council brown
just mentioned councilman golf
yeah good morning mr chairman apologies
for coming in late
um i'd just like to touch on the it's
only a small development that we're
looking at at the moment
and the fact that you've kept the
affordable element in here is that to me
is absolutely fantastic
um i i don't agree with trying to keep
the
garages with the affordable houses you
know they provided a an affordable house
that to me is affordable for somebody to
purchase it
and being a cancerous boy myself there's
there's no stigma
they're living in they will be living a
nice development there anyway
and i was imagining me very happy to buy
one there so the affair development
given there's no five-year building
supply by torridge i think it's
fantastic so i do
um compliment the applicant on this
and i do i'm in support as mr chairman
thank you councilman mcgough
okay it's been moved
to accept uh approve move for approval
by council
seconded by councillor watson unless
anybody else has any comments can we go
through the vote please sandra
yes thank you chair councillor belton at
four
councillor brown boar counselor christy
or counselor craigie
or counselor leather for
chancellor locke councillor mcgough
four ancel watson oh
and councillor wiseman oh
that's unanimous chair thank you
thank you sandra right we move on to our
next application
which again is for this same site
dougie's field
in cheviot but it had to be a separate
application for the foul
and surface surface water drainage
because it's outside the uh outline for
the um
it's outside the red line for the
outline application that was already in
place
so again tracy will you present this
please
yeah thank you chair so yes um this is a
full application
for the foul and surface water drainage
to serve the seven dwellings of the
previous application
as the chair just said this is due to
the um
the the service and foul surface water
drainage being outside that red outline
of that previous application that we
we've just had a look at
likewise again there's no updates for
members on this application
so i'll just briefly run through this
because obviously it is the same site
so the location plan of the application
so the blue hatched area is where we've
just seen for the seven dwellings
um and then there's the red outline um
where it also annotates the package
treatment plant
to be um installed just south of the
dwellings
and um the studs uh pond which is to
uh the furthest south of the uh location
um this is an aerial photo again the red
arrow just indicates the southern end of
the site where the proposed foul and
surf of water drainage prepares to be
installed
um again this just gives members an
induction of an indication of the
location of the new package treatment
plants to be installed underground
and to serve as foul drainage for the
seven dwellings
and the surface water drainage is to be
dealt with via flood storage pond to the
southeast of the site
so this shows the detailed drainage
plans of the storage
uh flood storage pond so the pond has
been designed in accordance with the
sustainable drainage systems guidance
for divert devon
and the submitted drainage statute
confirms the capacity of the flood
storage is for 90 cubic meters
this is another drainage layout again
of the drainage of the detailed of the
suds pond
and showing the maximum capacity that it
holds
this is a cross-section drawing of the
studs pond detailing sort of shallow
side slopes which will reduce
any visual impact on the surrounding
countryside
so just very quickly to go through that
the material planning consideration of
the application
the disposal of the foul drainage is to
be dealt with by a new package treatment
plant to the south the approved
dwellings
the council's environmental protection
team is satisfied with the foul drainage
proposed that
that is to serve the seven dwellings the
surface water is to be dealt with virus
storage pond to the southeast
corner and that has been designed in
accordance with the suds guidance
so impact on character and landscape so
the flood storage pond is considered to
be acceptable with shallow sloping sites
which will reduce
any visual impact on the sloping on the
surrounding countryside
a package treatment plant obviously will
be installed underground so there will
be no adverse
landscape impact on that and the ecology
the application has been supported with
an ecology statement to confirm the
proposal will have
no impact on protected species so
therefore the recommendation for this
application chair is approval
thank you tracy um
well it's a street application nobody's
got their hand up to
speak to this councillor watson yes chad
thank you very much
um i i've gone through this and it's i
think it's a
a real good job what they've produced
here and i'll i'll
propose it thank you councillor watson
well i'm happy to second the proposal
council of the lock
muted road
i was just going to second that but it
was too late thank you
all right thanks council a lot okay it's
been moved
by councillor watson and seconded by the
leather
to approve this application sandra could
you go to the vote please
yes thank you chair councillor bounton
at four
councillor brown for councillor christy
oh answer craigie or
anson leather or pencil and lock
or pencil ma golf or
pencil watson and councillor wiseman
or unanimous chair
thank you sandra right we move on to
our next application which is five
hubberstone road
apple door uh change of use from offices
to hostile accommodation and chris
christian chris easley
our planning officer will give us this
presentation
thank you chair so um as you've um
rightly pointed out this is a change of
use of an office
um to a hostel and the application has
to be determined by
committee because it's um owned by
torres district council
if we go to the next slide we can see a
site plan
so the blue line indicates the ownership
and the red line is the site
and if we go to the next slide we can
see it in context
so you've got the main built settlement
of apple door to the north and you can
see the shipyard to the south um and
then there
this is sort of set in some industrial
buildings
uh so you've got garages to the west and
the
fish stock to the east um it is within
the settlement boundary of
door if we go to the next slide
this is the building so it's um one of
three cottages
or crutches styled buildings
[Music]
next slide i'm trying to
show you the context a bit more there's
a garage to the left an industrial
building
sort of in the background there next
slide
you can see the fish dock in the
background there
and then that's the extent of the
building that's
proposed to change use next slide
in the background you can just about see
the shipyard
um and you can see the cars parked as
part of the
garage to the right next slide please
this is what the change reviews consist
of so you've got the existing ground
floor plans on the left and the proposed
ground floor plans on the right so
it consists of a kitchen living room
utility room
bedroom and then on the first floor if
we proceed to the next slide
you can see some bedrooms um storage
area
and a shower room um
moving on sorry for flying through this
too fast
um the material considerations
uh planned considerations in this case
as
follows and hopefully you've read my
report
which sets them out and why i'm making
the recommendation of approval
and happy to take any questions you may
have and
pass back over to your chair thank you
chris thank you for the presentation
uh who'd like to start any questions on
this application
counselor watson yeah i took one or two
questions chris
could you go back to the to the to the
floor plans please
chris can you hear me okay yeah i can
leave sorry mate sorry it's all right
on the left hand side there there's a
doorway does that doorway go through to
another property
yeah i've um it does show on the plans
on the website but i've cut it off
because i thought it made it clearer um
about what we were actually considering
so that goes through to
what's number four now that is that is
an integral door but
it would be envisioned that that would
remain shut so it's just the door which
goes through to number
number four shooting locked
why do they need to keep it there as a
doorway i'd
that's the question really for our
property team um
it it's not a problem that's a
doorway in my own in my opinion there is
a chap that
uses it and you see in the
representations
he has an office next door and he has
used the shower
room in in this building um
as part of his office but that would be
a an agreement between himself and our
property team over there
that was my next question to you chris
because i didn't i don't understa
about the neighbor with the shower you
know
and i didn't realize it next door was
officers
because yes but maybe if you you
obviously mean
somebody that's living there so the
the neighbour at number four is is an
office right
so that that would that system would be
stopped that he could use the shower and
toilet
well i that's something i can't uh
commit to because that's an agreement
that he would have with our property
team so um
it might be it might not be that's
that's not really
for for me to consider okay chris
okay another one more question then what
is it actually going to be used for
and who is going to are are these things
going to be rented
or are the fish stock going to use it
so we were approached by the shipyard um
about having some short-term
accommodation
um people may travel from distance
to come work at the shipyard for just a
couple days for example
and they wanted some short-term
accommodation in close proximity that
they could essentially
run and uh have as their own sort of
thing so
that's that's the background to the
application
this is the shipyard that's not open yet
then
is that yeah so nothing to do with the
fish stock
no this is the what's the former babcock
shipyard
right okay chris that's that's fine
that's cleared that and
and if nobody else is uh going to speak
i'll propose that we approve it
thanks councillor watson uh councillor
locke
yeah i was gonna ask the same two
questions i was puzzled by the
uh neighbor had used of the shower
um and when i first read the report and
i saw the word hostel
i assumed it was going to be a homeless
hostel so it wasn't until i read the
full report that it was going to be used
by epidural shipyards
so i'm all for supporting them in their
future opening
but as far as i know this is not a
planning issue but the torres district
council owning the building
they're going to pay the repairs are we
going to charge
rent to the arbiter there's all will
people be able to live there
or you know uh stay there as of when
required or will we get some return
well didn't really yeah it's not really
a planning
issue though that counseling i did say
that but that's the point of interest
and i don't think chris could could
answer that really i
i would have to ask our property team um
i i would make a presumption that
nothing in life is free but
um that is a presumption okay that's
okay chris
i'm happy okay thanks uh it's been
did you second that one counselor log
yes i will second that one
thank you unless anybody else wants to
speak on this one then
um i think it's been explained exactly
what the change is it's
from offices to that as you see on the
screen there
so it's been moved by councillor watson
for approval secondly by council lock
sandra could you take the vote please
yes chad
councillor bangtan at four
pence lebron four penciller christie
or pencil craigie or
ansler leather poor counselor lock
or pencil mcgough or
answer watson or counselor wiseman
or unanimous chair
thank you sandra right we move on then
to our final application which is
uh bought the barn at merryfield farm
on pages 48
um and sean you're giving us this
presentation on this one
uh yes chair thank you very much um so
this application relates to the
conversion of a barn to a dwelling
at merrifield farm bridge the
application number is one slash one zero
five six
slash twenty twenty slash full and it's
pages 48 to 58
on uh members agendas next slide please
the applications before members as the
applicant is a member himself
and there are no verbal updates uh
following the publication of the agenda
members will be familiar with the site
following the virtual site visits that
was undertaken remembers
last week so i'll quickly run through
the slides just to refresh
members memories um the site is to the
north of maryfield farm as shown on the
plan
in front of you at the moment it's to
the east of the b3254
some six miles east of butte five miles
west of holsworthy
and one mile south of bridgeville
next slide please
this just gives a little bit of the
context of the relationship of the barn
to the actual farmstead
at maryfield farm it is a countryside
location
and lebron is positioned on a hillside
there is sporadic development
surrounding
in the wider area including tourism use
industrial use
and dwellings and to the south of that
aerial photograph
members will be able to see the ritual
industrial estate
next slide
so just a few photographs given the
context of the site this will be the
access track it's an existing access
track which will gain vehicle access to
le barn
this is accessed through merrifield farm
as we can see with the photograph on the
left there is a
hard standing gravel standing which goes
slightly overgrown as you go further up
the track as shown on the right hand
side
with hedge banks to either side it is
wide enough to accommodate
a vehicle next slide
this is a photograph of the south and
east elevation of the existing barn
it is disused and redundant and due to
its limited size
is of limited use for modern
agricultural practices
next slide please
this is the east elevation as members
have previously seen
the barn is formed from stone elevations
with red brick detailing
under a slate pitch roof next slide
lebon is currently in danger of falling
into disrepair
and it's whilst it's not a designated
hedges asset it is of some interest as a
traditional stone farm building
next slide uh apologies for the quality
of the photograph this sunrise i'll see
if we
have a low in the sky this is just a
quick picture of the
north elevation next slide
uh internally you can see evidence of
the disrepair
with some slate starting to fall into
the floor
internally it has a cobbled floor some
evidence of former
white washing on the walls and also on
the right-hand picture
some evidence of a mezzanine a former
mezzanine level which would have been a
hayloft
next slide
so moving on to position and the views
from the barn this is a view
west over our cultural land uh the coast
is just in the distance
um with agricultural buildings and you
probably can't see it below is a caravan
park
just beyond the hedge layer in the
distance
uh we zoomed on that at the site visit
so members will be aware of that
next slide
this is a view south down towards
mayfield farm and there's
associated a residential dwelling there
you can see at the bottom of the hill
next slide
this is the view north uh which gives
quite a good understanding of the
location of the building on the
hillside on hilltop in the distance
there you can see the
development of all the settlement or
ritual
next slide
again a poor photograph i apologize to
members this is the view
east which shows a boundary stone wall
sorry boundary concrete block wall
enclosing a
existing yard area and countryside
beyond
next slide
the barn being on hillside position is
in a prominent location from a
particular viewpoint on the b3254
highway
and i've tried to show that on this
photograph and highlighted the
barn with that red arrow
the view of the bond does disappear this
is the um only prominent viewpoint on
the b3254
and because of the topography and the
hedge banks as you move further north
view of that bond then disappears but
from this location it is rather
prominent
next slide so moving on to what's
actually proposed
uh the plans as you can see in front of
you
involve the conversion of the barn with
an extension to the south
southern elevation a
cutlass area which includes parking uh
to the north
east for two cars and
the catholics basically includes the
existing yard area
which is bounded by the concrete block
wall and a
cartilage to the north next slide
so moving on to the elevations the
proposed elevations
as we can see the extension is to the
south
of the barn the extension will be formed
by
two fixed glazing units on each side of
the elevation east and west
under a pitched profile sheet roof
the gable end as we can see will be a
stone gable end and that will be
constructed on the existing
on the existing boundary wall which i'll
show you in the next photograph
so this is a view looking west and
members will see where the location of
the extension will be
with that gable end uh constructed on
that what is the existing boundary wall
next slide
so just for example obviously floor
plans that are proposed um as you'll see
from the top floor plan there that's a
ground floor
is open plan living it will be a one
bedroom dwelling over the bedroom formed
on a mezzanine level
as shown on the lower floor plan next
slide
so quickly moving on to the main
planning material planning acceleration
for this application members will have
read my report but if i quickly run
through
uh principal development it is in a
countryside location
where members need to consider policy
st07 however it
is rural building reuse so the principle
is accepted
um policy dm 27 also bites in relation
to
the reuse of the building just used a
redundant building
and in your office's view it does a
court of that policy as shown in the
committee report
design and appearance if we just go back
to the elevations slide if you may
so designing an appearance the design is
somewhat contemporary as members will
appreciate
used by due to the fixed lasing unit and
the user profile sheet
it is considered that whilst
contemporary it is an acceptable design
as it does demarcate the traditional
form of the existing
farm building which is of some heritage
interest
the profile sheet roof again profile
sheeting is quite prevalent in our
cultural buildings in the area
so whilst it does add like that
contemporary nature it's not seen as
something
that you officer would recommend refusal
on that basis
the fixed glazing units does also cause
some concern with regard to
uh light pollution given the hillside
location
um again it will be seen in the country
of the sporadic development
that's around the barn and also
once it is our cultural building with no
lighting on it at the moment there is
nothing to stop
the um owner of the site putting
lighting on that barn for our coach
presses in the future
so whilst there will be some additional
light pollution again that's not
considered significant enough robust
enough to result in a reasonable refusal
and just go back to the consideration
slide
in terms of residential immunity there
are no near neighbors
so there won't be any issues with
overlooking or privacy
you'll know there is a condition
recommended in terms of contamination of
the land
and that's in line with the
constellation spontaneous environmental
protection team
highways and parking the proposal does
provide um
two uh parking places uh the
it has been viewed by the devon county
council highways authority
you have raised no objections and
there's good visibility available
um onto the b3254 uh
drainage um a there will be a drainage
solution
in the form of a sewage treatment plant
um
this has been looked at by man to
protection and again i've got no
no objections to that ecology
there are some there is some ecology
interest in the barn
as you'd expect given the the
condition of labon and the materials in
the swallows nest
uh this is reflected in a condition uh
placed uh that members will notice in a
report
um which is in accordance with the
ecology report
so in terms of the planning balance uh
it's considered that the pearl does
record the development plan and
therefore
the recommendation is one of approval
subject
conditions listed in the report and i'm
happy to take any questions that members
may have
thank you chair thank you and before i
bring with one speaker for this it's
councillor ken james the applicant
can i just ask sean if we have anything
from bridge real
bridgewood parish council uh no chair no
response from bridal
okay thanks right well
the only speaker for this application is
uh councillor ken james the applicant so
i shall bring in ken james to speak to
it
right thank you chair um i did debate
whether to speak or not
um but um all i'd say is that it's a
very thorough report it's been a very
thorough exercise to get to where we are
um the project started five years ago by
my daughter
and for family reasons it got left which
is why the bars deteriorated slightly
um but when we came to berryfield some
years ago there was virtually no
uh buildings here for livestock so that
one was used for a fair while for
bullets which is why they um hail off
dismissing
from the sheep we've converted other
barns in the hamlet here
basically it's become quite a uh
seems to be a desirable hamlet i don't
quite know why um so we have moved all
the cattle right away from all the other
hoses in the hamlet
and this is we're not quite the last
project because we've now got a
redundant milking parlor
but it took me 10 years to do one of the
other barns and we've been five years on
this one
so it will be probably way after me
before anymore was done
um and also part of the project there in
in doing the lane up is that we're
restoring
some of the build canal in the wheel pit
which is actually
across the lane from that building and
we used to get lots and lots of visitors
come to see it but it's got overgrown so
we've started to
restore that um and also what
um didn't appear on the screen was when
you drive down the 3254
yes you can see the barn for about two
seconds there is a very large
um caravan site on the left-hand side
which you can see
when you come out of off dem uh debris
store
stone mall so um it's not
actually um going to be prominent at all
and we have left some ash trees in front
of it that will give
um some uh tree cover during the summer
so that's all i want to say um so thank
you very much for listening
thank you council james right our first
committee member to speak on its council
mcgoff
yeah thank you mr chairman um i'd like
to move straight away that we
move these recommendations on the page
as you see um it's
to me it's a lovely design there there's
no arm to the landscape
and i like the contemporary design it
actually fits well and to be honest
making use of a dilapidated agriculture
building is paramount to some of the
farmers now
um coming forward for the pandemic so i
fully support it and
wish the applicant the best of luck it's
a great development and i'll be going
smoothly from
thank you councilman goff councillor
locke
yeah i was going to ask about bridgewald
paris council but that's been answered
my only is not really a concern but um
with the extension and the two fixed
large
glazing units that go from top to bottom
um would it be a reasonable condition
to add a condition that anti-glare glass
is put into these
openings because if you're driving along
the road and the sun catches it you know
just a second looking at it so i don't
know what the officer says about that if
we could condition anti-glare glass but
otherwise i'm in full support of the
application
sure yeah if i can respond chair uh
thank you councillor locke
um now the term anti-glare is fairly
wide-ranging
uh so i'd be concerned about how exactly
that is within a condition
what we could place is a condition that
we see a
sample of the glass before
before development commences and
in that way we'd have some control of
what that glass is
just saying anti-glare there's levels of
anti-glare etc
and i'm not sure that would necessarily
do what members or what council look
would wish to um which to happen
could i suggest then that we do ask the
condition that a sample of the glass
is provided
yes if we uh chair if we can um as
always dedicate the wording of that to
uh myself and yourself as chair um
and the wording alongside the sample of
anti-glare glass is provided prior to
development
um that would be acceptable yeah okay
one other further point being marital
drama
um on one of the slides there are
feed cattle barriers in place will they
be removed the way how near to the barn
are those captain feed barriers
i know you said counselor james that you
removed cattle from around the area
so i didn't know whether it was your
intention to remove the feed barriers
uh from if i'm just chip in a chair
i haven't got any detail of that from a
planning application perspective
if we just go to the layout slide
no that one there that's fine
whereabouts were they council lock were
they the ones that
were on the boundary wall ballet trees
that yeah yeah on the on the eastern
side i think they were
yeah they're not showing they're on that
layers are they
no i'm just straining my eyes trying to
look at a small print
yeah the development will be as per
proposed in the slide that you're
looking at now in the site plan
um so that's how that's what it will
encompass
yeah it's probably outside i don't know
if it's a illusion
we may want to go to the applicant to
the applicant online to discuss that it
was not in his head
and yet
oh all right thanks councilman
councillor watson
yeah thanks thanks jeff um i i
i agree with a lot and i did notice
councillor james when she brought up
about the
the feed barriers or whatever they
called he was nodding his head to say
yes they were going to be
removed and also one other point is the
photographs he showed
off them off excuse me off the main road
like
you would not want to be driving down
that road and looking for that bomb
to be quite honest because i mean i know
that road and you would not want to look
for it because
some sometimes they drive up crazy down
there but
i'll i'll second the application um
because i think we've got someone who
has gone in to propose
that's it mcgoff has proposed it yeah
i'll second i'll second that chair
that it's approved thank you what with
the additional condition
with the additional conditions yes
sample of the glazing for those two
large
yeah check can you check with councillor
mcgough that he's happy with that
condition as well please
you you're happy with that councilman
mcgough
mr chairman yeah i'd like to obviously
touch onto that one there i am happy
with that condition it goes
through the chair and obviously um mr
harrison himself
um it's a good point raised by
councillor locke and i am happy to add
that into the recommendation
okay thank you councilman mcguff
nobody else got the hand up to speak but
some of the issues that i was
thinking about this have been addressed
the light pollution issue was one that
did concern me
it is a prominent site and i take what
council watson said that
you wouldn't look for it but you
wouldn't notice it at night normally
but once it's lit up inside um
there is obviously going to be a certain
degree of
light pollution from it but i do think
that
council locks point about the glazing is
a very valid
point and i'm glad she's raised up
because i do remember
these solar panels imbued once the glare
from those
and they needn't have been because you
can get very
anti-glare glass these days for solar
panels or for glazing
in general so i do think if the sun had
caught those
it could be like a great beam of light
up there on those because they are very
large
those two panels the only thing i would
like to add
if councillor mcguff is agreeable too is
a condition about
an integrated box bat box in a bird box
because
there is evidence of swallows nesting on
that barn
and i think it's awful if a swallows
come all the way back from south
south africa and his home's gone that's
a shame
i love to see swallows on barns and i do
think i'm pretty sure
i would imagine that councillor james
would be quite happy to do that
so i'd like to us to put a condition in
i'm not as bothered about the bat box
because
there's not been any evidence of bats in
that building
but certainly swallows and i would like
um
a condition that not just one a couple
of swallow boxes are put up under the
eaves there
and if if councilman goff's happy sean
you've
want to come in on that yes thank you
chair um just to bring your attention to
condition four
that's proposed um which is the
development should be carried out in
accordance to the recommendations set up
within the submitted
baton nesting bird report um
fully avoidance that mitigation includes
a timing works outside the swallowing
nesting seasons and if we refer to that
report
um the recommendations are building work
should not commence during the swallow
and nesting season which occurs between
april and september it is recommended
that works commence prior to nesting
season
and must be sufficiently advanced to
certainly returning pairs but also
alternative nesting habitat swallows
shall be made by installing swallow nest
cups
or by creating a deep overhang at the
eaves and also
the biodiversity of the structure may be
increased by the incorporation of one
integrated bat box and one integrated
bird box
so while there's no evidence of bats at
the moment we could be seeking a
biodiversity net gain by including a
bat box so that condition does cover
that
but um equally we can um
we can focus that condition to actually
require those elements if it pleases
just on page 55 i was reading that
it said for these matters can form a
planning condition
so and i did read four i did read
condition four and it wasn't clear
there that they were actually going to
be installed but if you're happy with
how four is worded now and that they
will be installed there that's fine
yeah all right right so they will be
installing so
can we move to the vault then sandra
please
thank you chair councillor benton
paul chancellor brown
boy ansa christie
ansel craigie or hansen
watson um four
councillor wiseman four
that's unanimous chair thank you sandra
right now we move on then that's the
last of our applications
we move on then now to item seven on the
agenda which is appeal
decisions on pages 59-63
you'll see that one was refused
move on to item eight costs on appeals
there are no costs
on the appeals nine is delegated a g
mb decisions on page 64.
and then we move on to 10 then which are
the planning decisions that have been
issued on pages
65 to 68 so i'll go through those pages
65
66 councillor christie
oh yes can i just ask about the second
one down i don't quite understand it
part retrospective how can you be part
retrospective
sean um
that's a good question christie which i
don't have an answer for you at the
moment i'm not fully aware
of the details of the application um i
think this one it came
to northern's plans committee i think
that was looking at there
it's part of it's already been started
but some of it hasn't
so i think that's why it's part
retrospective because some of it has
already been started some foundations i
think have already been done
uh chair i can do a little bit of
research on that and then let members
know if that's helpful
okay it's page 66
time simplistic yeah it's gonna i'd just
ask about the one third from the bottom
this is about asda
um unless you've got a supermarket in
your ward you're probably not aware that
the government has um said that during
the kobe crisis
the hours of deliveries can be altered
because
we've always put on fairly strict hours
because it can upset people if these
lorries arrive you know four in the
morning with their
refrigerator units going and can i just
ask this one has been
suspended for 12 months but do torridge
do we actually
have a calendar for these so the
officers can go back and check
because i'd hate this just to drift
through
uh because nobody checks up after 12
months do we actually flag these up do
we have a calendar
uh yes we can monitor those through our
enforcement team
clearly if we uh receive complaints we
would actually
um investigate that in any case um even
if it's within 12 months
but we're aware of our temporary
permissions um and when they expire
because temp admissions also include
things like our coach workers dwellings
of course um so we've got quite a broad
range of temporary permissions
thank you thank you sean uh
page 67
page 68. good way
right well that's the last of our agenda
items
so i'll declare at 25 to 11
the meeting close thank you to members
of the public
yeah we were talking earlier about
duncan county council rep
coming to a committee meeting do you not
think because
you know there was so there's so many
sites um sites of schools proposed and
always comes 106. do you not think it
might be wise
to have a separate meeting just a half
an hour or an hour with
educational authority to go through
everything rather than try and lump it
in
on the plans committee agenda i'd agree
with that rose
well i i did think about that but i was
thinking that
yeah if um i don't know how long-winded
it need to be
but i was just thinking that if it was
done in a during the public part of the
meeting
any members of the public listening any
agents would be
privy to whatever was said by the
education uh
officer yeah but if you had a separate
meeting you could still admit members of
the public
yeah not normally when we've finished
our plans committee
and uh youtube is switched off that's
when we usually discuss things then but
yeah we could keep we could put it on
the end of a plans committee meeting
or now we're still still meeting by zoo
i mean it's so easy to just set up a
meeting and
i know we've had several extra meetings
but i think it will be worthwhile for
all concerns
it is costly rose to set up a meeting
well i think tom and tom could answer
that
sorry tom i'm happy to host an extra
meeting if required by the chair
well you've just chickened out there tom
all right
can i just say thank you to those who've
watched on youtube